this is a very high profile interview it
is the first time that
megan and harry have sat down to tell
their side of the story that's
simply why they are doing this and of
course that is a cause of concern for
the royal family
uh for courtiers at buckingham palace
just really relieved and happy to be
sitting here
talking to you with my wife by my side
because i can't begin to imagine what it
must have been like for her
going through this process by herself
all those years ago
because it has been unbelievably tough
for the two of us but at least we had
each other
we know that one of the things megan is
going to be asked about is the
is the subject of race what it was like
being a biracial woman marrying into one
of the oldest
establishments in the world the house of
windsor um
there will be people that are very
nervous about that and oprah wouldn't be
doing her job of course
if she didn't ask the difficult
questions she's going to want to know
the truth about the feud with william
and what kate was really like
as a sister-in-law for megan these are
going to be the things that will worry
the palace and i'm sure worry the royal
family too
i think that this interview absolutely
has the potential to
to damage relationships within the royal
family i mean
harry's relationship with his brother
was only just getting
back on track if he's going to discuss
why they fell out
that's set to blow the rift wide open
and set that healing process back
if the royal family come in for
criticism if megan
suggests that she wasn't made to feel
welcome and again that could cause
real damage for already fragile family
relationships
almost sounds like there was a breaking
point
my biggest concern was history repeating
itself in the same way that there are
always going to be comparisons between
kate and diana i think
megan is is going to be compared for
many years to come
to wallis simpson she is american she's
a divorcee
her and her husband have now left the
royal family and and
and left for another country so i
suppose it's inevitable there's someone
somewhere is going to try and set them
up as
a similar fashion icons i think megan
has her very
own um sense of style i think it's i
think it's nothing really more than
coincidence but i do think you can
expect to see
a lot more comparisons between wallace
simpson and megan for obvious reasons
you've said some pretty shocking things
here wait
hold up wait a minute there are reports
that this interview has been in the
works
for two years i mean it has also been
reported that
uh harry megan had only met oprah once
before inviting her to their wedding
and oprah has been somebody um
planning for this interview ever since
that day clearly a sit down with the
sussexes
was always going to be a big property to
get and
and this has been one of the most
publicized
eagerly awaited of all royal interviews
clearly this interview comes at um at a
very difficult time for the royal family
i am told that
while buckingham palace has denied
having anything to do
with the times splash over this email
alleging that megan bullied two members
of staff out
they are much more concerned with the
more serious matter which is the health
of the duke of edinburgh who is
seriously ill in hospital and there are
calls by some
royal commentators and experts who
believe that this interview
and should be rescheduled and aired at a
less sensitive time for the royal family
and there are even some reports
circulating online that prince harry is
being asked to come home
um to see his grandfather no
confirmation from that
and from either the palace or the sussex
exposed people but inevitably
um this is going to be a source of much
speculation
and the timing really couldn't be any
worse for the royal family this
interview coming
at such a difficult time